I've never met a foreigner who doesn't speak
ill of other foreigners.  Seeing a child having fun or
seeing a cockroach in the house kept me sane
I've already made a meme about my achievements,
but
I seriously don't use
faxes.  I've never met anyone before, but I
've just had a shaky conversation with the store clerk in charge of the cash register
about paint
.
I
've never seen a salarier that doesn't use a laptop.
Have you
ever heard someone say that they climbed the mountain but it was surprisingly easy?
I've never met a woman who knows how great dj krush is.
In the first place,
I'm envious of what happened to people who knew dj
krush
.
I've talked to people who can
do it, and I've never been told to start playing business Perth now, not next week
.
I've seen people me